so now we're going to differentiate
between scientism and
science after reading that little
history and kind of going through what
scientism is
like uh here's what science is as
opposed to realism science is actually
anti-realism and what is
that scientific theories are models
which represent the data in the most
coherent way possible but are not
considered true in the absolute sense
and are subject to human biases in many
ways a theory is the same as a
t okay it's a commentary Of The World Is
A Commentary of what we see I perceive
something but just because I perceive it
does not necessitate that I have the
appropriate interpretation for example a
mirage if I don't know what a mirage is
and I come upon a mirage in the desert
I'm going to assume that it's probably
Water
right until of course I approach it and
I realize that's not the case and it's
just an illusion and then I realize how
a mirage works and in the future I you
know I can ascertain that this is not
really
water okay uh whereas a realist would
say whatever they see is exactly the
case until they you know whatever
they're perceiving that interpretation
is actually as it is and one of the
reasons that anti-realism is more
popular within the philosophical
Community is because as we know from
history not just from the WR not just
from the uh the explanation by Thomas
and others but we know
that this can't be true because theories
are changing all the
time okay so a few few questions
here anonmouse if science is just a
framework for understanding the world
why cannot flat earthers observe the
data and propose of Flat Earth as a
theory that's a good question and the
reason they can but
it has to be more more coherent than the
other than the other Theory you see what
I'm saying that's how you judge them
okay um so for instance if one theory
has a better way of explaining all the
data versus another theory then we
reject the other Theory because the
other theory is useless it doesn't help
us in any way well speaking of which I
forgot to mention that and and Carl
poer had a debate in one and Carl
poer eventually had to admit that he was
wrong um so yeah I I wanted to go into
that whole drama it was very interesting
you can read up on yourself uh but it
was a really cool
debate clarification by anti-realist uh
do you mean in an epistemic sense rather
than ontological sense another question
I meant in an epistemic sense I'm sorry
yes this is all epistemology we're not
talking about ontology here uh now when
you say somebody is a realist they
believe that what they're seeing is
actually the case okay but anti-realist
will say no what I perceive is not
actually the case it's just a construct
you know it's it's you know um there is
actually a reality behind that construct
but what I'm perceiving as is is not
exactly that okay because human beings
cannot step outside of my and you know
this is the problem with with realism as
well is that is considers to be
objective right and what does objective
mean well there are two meanings one is
that factual the other is so that's what
we use in the colloquial sense the other
one is perception outside of the
subjective sense so people have this
weird idea nowadays that they can jump
outside of their brain and kind of like
see everything as it is but that's not
how it works um everything that we
perceive is from the subjective lens
okay there is nothing that that humans
perceive and and their biases don't
touch do you understand like I cannot
interpret the world outside of my own
perspective it's not possible
which is another reason that realism is
stupid okay so anti-realism next what
else is science reality
pragmatism people consider this a dirty
word it's not in the scientific
Community or at least among scientific
philosophers so what is pragmatism and
this is probably the most popular
version of science today within the
philosophical community and this is the
one that Thomas and Willard Quin
and said followed and this is the reason
that the that logical positivism and
scientism were defeated it was by these
philosophers okay the pragmatist
movement uh I don't know if you're aware
of an individual by the name of
um Jordan Peterson Professor Jordan
Peterson whether you agree with him or
not uh he has a lot of interesting ideas
in terms of psychology and he is a
pragmatist okay pragmatist philosopher
uh okay so pragmatism science is a tool
and theories are validated based on
their usefulness and coherence so
whatever Theory makes the most
predictions and whatever Theory most
coherently takes the data and makes a
good explanation out of it is the best
theory that's it it's not it's it's not
because it's true it doesn't make it
true it just makes it the best theory
that's it so that there's your answer to
your flat Earth versus round earth flat
earthers are are are are ridiculous
because their their Theory
doesn't answer really any of the
problems it doesn't actually explain
anything they try they just deny what
the round earthers are saying that's all
they really do it's just like atheists
deny what theists are doing atheists
never really propound their own theories
they just say hey that's wrong because
there's no evidence I'm smart and that's
it that's really all they do okay oh I'm
sorry Ahmed farage um what about God of
the gaps if it's the only explanation
that we have I don't really understand
your question could you make it more
clarify that please and I'll continue
and come back to you
oh abues this sounds very conent oh yes
is the Islamic perspective about realism
closer to conent hum or cartisian or
something more nuanced oh no no no no no
um first off it is more nuanced
um it is not Conan it's not humean it's
not cartisian it's more of a hiigaran
and cian understanding um the
demarcation between the reality and the
subjective is really superficial I'm
sorry for all of you out there I'm just
answering this question but for you you
don't understand I apologize I'll try to
explain it the distinction between what
is outside what is externally real and
what is within our subjective
perspective is a superficial distinction
because we can't understand anything
other than what we subjectively
perceive so we can only assume that that
there's a difference you see what I'm
saying um whereas carians humans and
conans would say well uh there's this
like whole other world out there you
know that that we're just not
perceiving um that is behind the veil
you know what I mean and that's more
like a Ser
Sufi understanding of things I'm not
going to go into Sufi metaphysics I'm
not Sufi but I'm just telling
you something like a mulas sadra thing
going
on
um
so yeah I hope that answered it to some
extent okay going
on I apologize I'm a little parched
right now so instead of being
Progressive it's paradigmatic okay what
does that mean so instead of being
gradual science is not Progressive but
adaptive as humans obtain more data
about the natural world theories are
updated and tweaked until they can no
longer account for said data and then
they are replaced by a new and
dissimilar system with its own rules and
languages so basically like uh you have
a program right you can you keep
updating it when it has like viruses or
it has like problems and you keep
updating or you update a new version 2.0
2.3 2.5 you know and then eventually you
just get rid of the whole thing because
it's a bad this is a bad program you
replace it completely that's basically
in a similar way how how how science
works you have one theory that works for
a certain time it explains what it needs
to explain and then as you collect more
data the theory is
not quite accurate and then you change
the theory to accommodate the
information so it's not like the
information is like coming into your
head and then your theory just forms
randomly in your mind what we do as
humans is that we observe the world and
then outside of that we come up with a
construct ourselves a commentary from
our own minds that makes that coherent
so something else atheists don't
understand a lot of them don't is that
they think that the information just
sort of like slams into their brain and
all of a sudden they're like oh I
understand the world like no that's not
how it works in fact we come up with the
theory sometimes before we even make the
observations for example black
holes how do we come up with the idea of
black holes does somebody see a black
hole no somebody saw some anomalies some
differences some some Strange Behaviors
in the universe and then they decided to
come up with a theory for it to explain
what it was and then they saw more
observations which confirmed that theory
and then come up with this concept we
still don't even understand what black
holes are exactly anyway but the the
whole concept behind black holes as
being a theory as being as being
considered a fact now is is because we
actually somebody sat down one day and
literally just came up with this idea to
solve these problems that we were seeing
in the universe that was it that's
really what black holes are we've never
actually seen them uh evolutionary
theory is very similar to
that yes Darwin wanted to understand why
species were changing and why they they
had similarities as well he came up with
this Theory and it's I'm going to be
honest with you guys I don't follow
every aspect of it like I don't believe
that you know our cousins were apes or
anything but most of evolutionary theory
is quite sound it is quite
sound um in terms of uh of uh what we
consider to be what excuse
me I'm trying to look at micro adapt
things like this mutations in fact
without evolutionary theory we would not
understand viruses today or bacteria we
need it for a lot of things now does
that mean everything about evolutionary
theory is correct no it doesn't even
have to be this is another reason that
atheists often make these mistakes they
keep going around saying oh this is a
pure 100% truth fact it's like what are
you talking about have you not read The
History of Science do you have no you
have no idea what's happening do you
right now you're in you're you have a
paradigm that shift will occur
it's going to occur it always
occurs it's just a matter of
time
um we do we don't have enough
information yet to confirm whether it's
the most correct view of things yet we
still have a long way to go in fact
Evolution as we know it today could be
completely changed in the next hundred
years we have no idea okay um so science
isn't really a search for truth what do
you mean by
truth
I'm not I'm not a relativist by the way
but what do you mean by
truth I mean think about it do you have
absolute knowledge of the world no you
do
not is truth does that correspond with
something directly or is truth in
reality the most
coherent understanding of
something answer that question do you
follow Islam because you have direct
observ a knowledge of God of Allah of
the
Angels
no did Abu
Bakr did he did he when he was asked
about the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam when he went to the night
Journey when he was asked do you believe
this what was his what was his
response I believe something even more
incredible than that I believe that
Allah is is sending Revelation to him so
Abu Baka didn't believe it because oh I
saw it happen he believed it because it
was it was the most coherent thing for
him to
believe why not of course I do I believe
this
right so theories can be constructed
without observation yes they
can but in a different
way yes it's true that observation
experiment are Central to science but on
a periphery level
meaning that direct observations aren't
always necessary to understand things
our minds act as an interpretation
machine like a like a like a t we have
to be able to coherently see like if you
look at something okay if you look at
something you've never seen before you
don't have an interpretation of that
right because you don't I you don't know
what it is just because you're looking
at it the thing itself doesn't doesn't
inform you of what it is you have to
actually think about it right
if if somebody who's lived in a desert
for their whole life and never seen
never seen an ocean they can understand
it to some degree it's water but they're
like whoa what is
this that's not really a good example
I'm trying to think or a mirage a mirage
is probably a better example if you
first time you've ever seen a mirage
you've never heard of one do you have
any good reason to believe it's not
water right I mean your interpretation
is wrong but you don't have any other
means to understand it because you've
never seen it before you you don't know
what how it's created you don't know how
it's
formed are there holes in evolution
Theory you guys really like
Evolution okay sorry guys give me one
second I'm talking a
lot I'm gonna be honest with you I don't
have a problem with Evolution that much
um and I'm not a liberal by any means
I'm I'm author by Creed and uh I have I
have a very um conservative approach but
I can say that the majority of
evolutionary theory does not conflict
with Islam at all um there are holes
just like in any other Theory there
still answers that need to there's still
questions that need to be answered and
problems that need to be
addressed how do you deconstruct
Arguments for logical posit I'm going to
answer all these questions by the
way how do you deconstruct Arguments for
logical positivism well people aren't
really logical positivist today they're
mostly
scientist they follow
scientism and the first thing you have
to do is you challenge it in the same
way you challenge logical positivism
okay if science is the only means to
know anything well how is that statement
or that explanation you're making how is
that scientific what scientific evidence
do you have of that and usually atheists
will say well well we have they will
usually bring some other proof outside
of that own of that own verification
in order to prove it they'll say well
science works so they might use some
some pragmatic concerns we'll say well
okay but that's not answering the
question because you just said that
science is the only way to know anything
and just because it works doesn't
necessitate that you've proven that
statement correct you see what I'm
saying what is the Islamic comprehension
of H H
is okay truth um and I think even Tamia
took a very similar position in this
sense it was more about coherence than
it is about
correspondence correspondence requires
you to have direct observable knowledge
of a subject and the only people who
ever think that way are what I would say
are are certain classes of sufis who
think they can have that sort of
knowledge I'm not going to comment on
whether or not that's true or not but
from my understanding it is
impossible please verify with your own
Scholars but it's impossible for that
sort of knowledge to be had about God or
anything else direct observable
knowledge in that respect it just
doesn't work you cannot you cannot
perceive God you cannot see God's
attributes you cannot experience God's
attributes like that 100% okay it's just
not gonna
happen um so when you say you're on the
HW what do you mean it's OB obviously
you don't mean that you you understand
God 100% right because that's
impossible so it must mean that you have
the most coherent understanding of God
that's the only logical conclusion you
can
reach uh can you please give some
references that document using Evolution
just by press impression based on skin
color and certain cultures yes Muhammed
zum um there's not direct I think there
are some treatises that were written
during the 18th and 19th centuries that
in this respect especially in French
which would have been translated because
French positivism was probably the main
factor behind
colonialism um French positivism you
look it up you'll find every atrocity in
the name of colonialism in Europe was
justified through this means and by the
way I know this is probably going to
make you all very angry but French
positivism was also adopted by the
reformed Ottoman Empire which is why you
got The Young
Turks that's right all the reforms of
tanzimat reforms were based on French
positivism French
society so now you know
kind of why we collapsed that's just a
clue
uh
next Anonymous uh is I'm sorry is
correspondence theory essentially
empirical then it is direct observation
in direct empiricism is it is what we
call dog dogmatic empiricism empiricism
in and of itself is not a problem as
long as it's it's constructed along a
more holistic understanding of reality
because for instance Quin was an
empiricist but he consided himself a
holistic empiricist where he believed
that you know you had to be coherent too
you couldn't actually like see the thing
you know what I mean um and then just
interpret it as it
is Imam gazal would have considered an
empiricist to some degree as
well okay so Anonymous attendee I'm
sorry guys I'm I have shortness of
breath so I apologize that I'm I'm not
talking very well can we import
scientific theories to the Muslim world
uncritically and teach them in our
schools or should we there be a review
to ascertain their compliance with the
Islamic worldview now see this is where
I can answer this question now because
we've gone through all of
this there is a current movement in the
Muslim world called the islamization of
knowledge which was started in turkey
and Malaysia uh specifically by um a man
by the name of
uh uh
Muhammad Malaysian
philosopher uh Islamic philosopher one
the only remaining today also a uh
somebody that hza YF respects and I I
also learned under there him very
briefly and his students when I was in
Malaysia
um he he he's the main proponent of this
Theory there are others as well like uh
um SM farooqi and others um and then you
have another school of thought called by
zodin sarder who's more liberal but he I
think he has a more correct
understanding
here's the thing you can import
scientific theories into your
classroom however it has to address
Islamic issues you don't have to
redefine the theory itself under an
Islamic world view I don't agree with
this perspective because you can't I
mean the thing is our values are what
determine how science operates that's
something I didn't get into much
discussion with because we have we don't
have much time but the reason for
instance that Muslims were so successful
early in our our history with science is
because we had a need we had a need to
be right we were just a new Empire we
had nothing we had no resources we had
nothing we needed what we needed weapons
we needed gold we needed to be able to
Mint gold you know we need to be able to
build buildings we need to be able to do
a lot of things so we because of this
need this desire we took the theories of
the Greeks and we modified them and and
and constructed new theories to develop
even as astronomical theories to assist
our Society nowadays the problem with
the Muslim world is that we borrow
everything from the West everything we
don't build anything we we have needs
but instead of providing for ourselves
by by taking those theories and and
modifying and doing our own thing to to
make our own stuff what we have done is
instead we've borrowed from everyone
else that's why the Arab world is so low
today I'm sorry to say in terms of
technology and and things like this
Ingenuity it's because they take
everything from the West everything and
right now the most advanced Islamic
country I mean if you want to call it
that it's up to you um I'm not going to
get into doctrinal disputes here but the
most advanced Islamic country or Muslim
majority Society is
Iran now
why why is that the case they are more
advanced than any other Muslim country
in the world in terms of medicine and
and even
Weaponry
why I'll tell you why because they can't
borrow that much theyve been surrounded
in sanctions so much that they've had to
rely on themselves and because of that
need that's why they're developing their
own stuff but in the rest of the Muslim
World we're so used to borrowing from
the West now because we've been
colonized Iran by the way was not which
is another historical fact they they
they broke away from that much earlier
than the rest of the Muslim
world
so
um once we decide to to work for
ourselves and for our own needs instead
of borrowing from the west and expecting
the West to provide for us that is when
the theories that we currently have will
be modified in accordance with Islamic
values and that we will start advancing
again because I'll tell you this right
now the reason the Golden Age existed
was not
because we borrowed from the Greeks
necessar or we just Advanced from them
no we took what they had and we changed
it
completely because it because we needed
it for something else we needed it for
our own our own values our own beliefs
and because of those changes we
destroyed all the nonsense that came
with aristan Philosophy for instance I
don't know if you realize this but um
Aristotle was also big into astrology
okay and that was also kind of a and as
Muslims became more you know aware of
their faith and more conservative they
got rid of that belief and as Muslims
became more liberal they started
adopting Aristotle again later on and
astrology and that's when we started to
sort of become Static
now that's a whole different subject we
hopefully we get into a different module
but I thought that'd be interesting for
you
okay uh is Islam falsifiable uh I don't
believe Islam is falsifiable because I
don't believe in falsifiability see Carl
popper came up with falsifiability he
believed that any sort of error that was
found in the theory in and of itself
just there you know if you found one
anomaly that means the entire Theory
needs to be scrapped so according to his
own logic and Thomas debated him he said
well according to your logic then
Evolution must be scrapped because it
can't be falsified we don't have
any there's and there are novali too so
what are we going to do so that's why
Carl poer had to eventually discard the
theory falsifiability is nonsense uh
nobody operates that way maybe at the
micro level of science but not overall
theories do not operate by
falsifiability if they did we wouldn't
have any theories because we'd all be
discarded the moment you see a problem
they would discard
them and no actually works that
way are there any Islamic reference
materials against Sam Harris writing
podcast no but if I ever debate
him that'll that'll hopefully be it I
wanted to debate him for so long
actually
um actually you know what I'm actually
thinking about writing something against
one of his recent works with Majin
noaz I'll let you
know so sorry toic Roshan thank you for
the question
next most atheists use science as
criteria for True nowadays so can this
argument be used as argument against a
criteria you give me an argument let me
see what it says P1 anything based on
limited knowledge cannot be criteria for
truth P2 Science is based on limited
knowledge therefore science cannot be a
criteria for truth no sorry it's a bad
argument no offense the reason it's a
bad argument is because truth is not
cannot be measured by limited
limitations um what do you mean by truth
then
because you don't have knowledge of
everything so by by the Same by the
logic of the own
argument that means that Islam can't be
true stuck with the law right so we
should be very careful in that
respect can you debate Neil de grass
yes you probably think I'm arrogant but
I'm not I've studied these guys like I
know them like the back of my hand you
can actually uh if you read my article
on Yen Institute you'll see I've
actually written
against a lot of these ideas of
orientalists regarding Islamic history
and science and I mentioned Neil degrass
Tyson
there what does false viability even
mean I think I already asked that didn't
I did I I answered that it just means
that something is proven to be
incorrect it it it results in an anomaly
or it results in a a problem so for
instance if you make a prediction and
that prediction doesn't come true
therefore it's
falsified it it doesn't ever question
whether or not the question itself or
the prediction itself is false you see
what I'm
saying could you crush Neil de grass did
everybody answer that yeah uh
Crush uh I don't know physically at this
point because I'm quite weak and he's
he's he's probably a little bigger than
I
am uh mentally in a philosophical
discussion yeah probably he's just a
scientist no offense a scientists I mean
they're very valuable people but in a
philosophical discussion they're really
bad
um next okay you said most parts of
evolution are okay muham so is the only
part that is wrong is that Adam said
descended with some common ancestry I
think common ancestry is one of the
biggest issues in general not just
because of Adam but just because the
theory itself is very unstable that that
part of the theory is very
unstable in fact that that part of the
theory is not even Central to the theory
itself um so it's you don't even need to
believe that to believe in
evolution you reason that scientists
like to push it so much is because they
want to undermine
religion
whatever there are many Christian
evolutionists by the way the whole
Catholic Church is made of evolutionist
if they can do it we don't have a
problem